salud en directo América de France 24
más Romero sala por supuesto con
nosotros en esta mesa de trabajo mar
buena mañana de viernes llegamos Ya
viernes el viernes feliz viernes y bueno
esta semana la Organización Mundial de
la Salud público datos sobre las
consecuencias de no hacer deporte en
nuestra salud en la salud de las
personas Sí yo creo que hace años
vivimos con ese mantra de que hacer
ejercicios bueno para la salud y la
verdad es que sí Ahora más adelante
explicaremos bien porque la Organización
Mundial de la Salud como bien decías
publicó un informe en el que alerta un
poco de Los costos que tiene no tener
una actividad física así sea leve
moderada en nuestra salud y en la salud
de todas las personas no el cálculo es
que 500 500 millones de personas de aquí
a 2030 entre 2020 y 2030 en 10 años van
a desarrollar alguna enfermedad no
transmisible a raíz de no haber tenido
una vida relativamente activa
físicamente estamos hablando por ejemplo
de diabetes o de enfermedades
cardiovasculares no del donde los vasos
sanguíneos Eso no tendrá un peso solo en
la vida de las personas sino que supone
también un peso muy grande sobre los
mismos sistemas de salud que tendrán que
enfrentar esta carga de enfermedad el
cálculo también era de 27.000 millones
anuales de dólares para los sistemas de
salud en términos de Cuidado no para de
hacernos una idea además de eso se
calcula que uno de cada cuatro adultos
actualmente no tiene una actividad
física prácticamente en su día a día mar
además de la responsabilidad por
supuesto de cada uno de nosotros de
cuidarnos de hacer ejercicio para el
bien en nuestra salud hay alguna
responsabilidad que tienen los gobiernos
Sí y eso es algo que a mí además siempre
me llama la atención y es que en general
con la dieta o con el deporte solemos
poner Mucho peso en la responsabilidad
del individuo cuando en verdad También
hay políticas públicas que se deberían
hacer al respecto igual que hacemos con
muchísimos otros temas de salud la misma
Organización Mundial de la Salud en este
informe destacaba que es menos del 40%
de los países de todo el mundo los que
tienen una política nacional funcionando
operativa digamos para promocionar el
deporte entre su población solo el 30%
tienen guías disponibles sobre la
actividad física recomendada para todas
las edades y el 40% eso son datos que me
parece muy importante menos más o sea el
40% de los países solo tienen vías
seguras por ejemplo para hacer deporte
esto es muy importante para la gente que
quiere salir a caminar quiere salir a
trotar o quiere salir en bici por
ejemplo no Entonces eso nos lleva esta
pregunta de cómo hacer el deporte
accesible por para todo el mundo y que
sea una posibilidad real de hecho para
tener esta realidad no hace falta ir muy
lejos recordemos los casos en Estados
Unidos de hombres afrodescendientes
afroamericanos que solo salían a correr
a hacer deporte y se han visto víctimas
del perfilamiento racial eso también es
tener vías seguras eso también influye
en la capacidad que tienen la gente de
hacer deporte y el director de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud en este
mismo informe también pues destacaba esa
importancia de que todos los países y
los gobiernos se impliquen la
implementaciones de políticas para que
la gente sea más activa y se pueda
beneficiar de todos estos pues
maravillas que tiene ser activos
físicamente
madre porque hacer deportes están
beneficioso para nuestra salud pues es
muy importante aquí decir que incluso
niveles muy leves de ejercicio de
actividad física como caminar
diariamente ya reportan beneficios no
hace falta que las personas vayan cinco
días a la semana al gimnasio para
considerarse físicamente activas en
general está asociado con menor riesgo
de enfermedades cardiovasculares menor
riesgo de diabetes también menor riesgo
de desarrollar algunos cánceres por
ejemplo el cáncer de el cáncer de
colon mejor calidad de sueño que influye
mucho como hemos visto en nuestra salud
mental y también para personas mayores
por ejemplo menor riesgo de caídas o de
hacerse menos daño cuando caen algo que
es muy importante a medida que avanzamos
en la edad porque sucede esto pues vamos
a poner un ejemplo no hacer ejercicio
reduce de media nuestro ritmo cardíaco
Eso hace que también la presión que
ejerce Nuestra sangre sobre las arterias
o sobre sanguíneos sea menor y que a la
larga sea un desgaste más pequeño
también pues eso no para nuestros vasos
sanguíneos o para nuestra corazón
también mejora la capacidad que tienen
las células de oxigenar haciendo que el
oxígeno tenga que trabajar que las
células tengan que el corazón Perdón
tenga que trabajar menos para oxigenar
todo nuestro cuerpo y baja también el
nivel de azúcar en sangre al requerirlo
como energía algo que en este caso
ayudaba la diabetes que era lo que
estábamos hablando no Además por ejemplo
este flujo de sangre en todo el cuerpo
se asocia a tener menos demencia
asociada con la edad sin duda alguna
beneficioso hacer ejercicio mar y pues
por supuesto el sedentarismo Pues podría
tener implicaciones negativas para
nuestra salud pero qué podemos hacer
para que las personas tengan más
actividad física claro y precisamente
cogiendo el hilo de lo que estabas
diciendo para mí yo creo que lo
importante es preguntarnos por qué hay
gente que no la está haciendo no y es
que nos tenemos que dar cuenta que el
mundo del fitness o el mundo del deporte
es muy excluyente para muchas personas y
se construye mucho por ejemplo sobre
esta culpa no de no estás haciendo
deporte Entonces eres una mala persona
estar en forma merece respeto no estarlo
significa que eres un vago cuando Además
de eso está hecho pues por parámetros
físicos visuales digamos muy
gordofóbicos además en los que muchas
veces no se corresponde a la realidad no
Además está atravesado por muchísimas
cosas para empezar por el género desde
que somos pequeñas no no tenemos acceso
al patio en el recreo a los juegos de
pelota por ejemplo que los niños Sí pues
así están jugando y desarrollando y
haciendo actividad física o también
además se ASUME que solo hacemos
ejercicio para adelgazarnos no para
mantener un buen tipo también por la
clase por la clase social quién tiene
tiempo para hacer ejercicio quién No
termina agotado de jornadas laborales o
quién tiene el dinero para pagar el
equipo para pagar el gimnasio entonces
todas estas dinámicas también las
tendríamos que tener en cuenta para que
el deporte realmente sea accesible para
todo el mundo desarmar un poco estos
prejuicios que existen sobre el cuerpo
sobre el género la edad o también para
la raza y preguntarnos cuáles son estas
exclusiones que han dejado tanta gente
por fuera del mundo del deporte y
también por fuera entonces de todos
estos beneficios que estábamos nombrando
ahora me quedo Entonces el mar que pues
evidentemente si sea una caminata de
media hora 20 minutos Pues no le cae mal
a nuestro corazón y a nuestra salud por
supuesto que no lo agradeceremos con el